yeah what is your uh go-to spread recipe
my go-to spirit rest me fettuccine
so how would how would someone like give
me the ingredients the same as like oh
we in prison you can buy all the same
[ __ ] you could buy so you could buy
fettuccine you could buy the real brand
of fettuccine
sees anything you think of they got it
in prison anything so when we see people
like doing like these struggle prisons
struggle prison that's that's County
Jail [ __ ] okay okay okay that's when
you're gonna see the noodles crunched up
in a bag you don't make you know you
don't touch noodles in person I just saw
a video and then went viral where they
were doing like Hibachi in jail oh yeah
[ __ ] take his whole bunk you know the
bunks is metal [ __ ] take his whole bunk
and scrape everything off of it and Fry
food on that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
crazy yeah that's some creative mode are
they still doing a lot of prison tattoos
yeah right now somebody getting typed a
thousand people get every day do you
have any tattoo you got in prison no I
was scared of that yeah no I feel you
I'd be sketched too yeah because I go
like you know they say you pay for what
you get when it comes to tattoo artists
I look bad so
they say it's easy for you to get
Hepatitis uh for prison tattoo and they
tell me that's all I needed to hear oh
thought I was going in there uh going
I'm talking about the first time I went
to prison I'm thinking I'm going there
and go get tatted up
doctor said oh yeah you know it's this
is one of the easiest ways to catch
hepatitis I say hepatitis to me is haze
to me so I'm like well you can't get rid
of it exactly I'm gonna like if it's
anything you can't get rid of I'm scared
of it [ __ ] herpes HIV hepatitis if I
if there isn't a cure for it I'm out for
real I'm saying like definitely